-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian and actor you know
from
"The King of Staten Island."
His comedy special "Ricky Velez:
Here's Everything"
premieres October 23rd on HBO
as well as streaming on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-By the way,
I'm Irish and Puerto Rican.
That's my mix.
That's what it is.
[ Cheers ]
No, no, no, no.
No, those people
should not hang out.
[ Laughter ]
Irish and Puerto Rican.
I'm just happy I'm not gay
because that's way too many
parades to go to.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Yo, where's Ricky at?"
"He got another parade, dawg.
He can't chill.
Sundays aren't good for him.
Don't hit him up on Sundays.
He parades a lot.
If you need him, he's on Fifth.
You go if you need him."
-Please welcome to the show
Ricky Velez, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show!
I'm so happy to have you.
-You have an audience.
-We have an audience.
And they're very happy.
-You have an audience.
-I'm especially happy
to have a stand-up out here
because I feel like, of everyone
who was robbed of an audience,
you know, I think live musicians
and stand-up comedians,
it was just, like,
the hardest thing to do.
You had a special ready to go.
COVID hit,
and you basically had to wait,
I mean, I guess about
a year and a half.
-I got canceled by God.
[ Laughter ]
-You got canceled by God.
That's the real cancellation,
yeah.
-God was like, "Not today."
[ Laughter ]
-When you first started
doing shows again,
because I know a lot of
comedians tried to figure out
weird ways to do shows,
did you any strange ones?
-Yeah, I did a few.
I had to stand in front of cars
and yell at them.
-You did some of
those car shows?
-They just beep,
and that means they're happy.
[ Laughter ]
It's usually the opposite.
-Yeah, it must be hard to rewire
the brain.
-They made me do a show
on a farm.
-What?
-You don't know how bad you're
doing until you hear a moo.
[ Laughter ]
It was terrible.
-So the moo is not like a beep?
The moo is not
"you're doing well"?
-Well, it's also weird when
your green room is a barn.
[ Laughter ]
You just start feeling like --
You're like,
"This is not Hollywood anymore."
[ Laughter ]
"This is strange."
-It must be nice to finally have
shot it and have it,
you know,
available for people to see.
-I guess.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
We appreciate your honesty.
One thing we have in common,
I think, you know,
when we do stand-up,
we like to talk
about our family.
You got a 3-year-old?
-Yeah.
-Was it nice to be able to go
out and talk about him?
-I mean, I needed to get away
from him.
-Yeah. It's a nice reason, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We just did a full year
together.
I'm out. I'm done.
[ Laughter ]
I'm getting back on the road.
Miami is nice, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm getting out on the road,
and I'm going to talk about you,
kid."
Is he pretty good
at giving you material?
Do you feel like --
You know, again, as a stand-up,
I think that's the reason
to have kids.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I think I get more
from my wife.
-Yeah. How is she with it?
Is she okay with you taking --
-Time to time.
But, like, she knows she beats
me, like, mind-wise.
Like, she's very educated.
-Yep.
-And I went to a school
with a commercial.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's not a good school.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
I feel like that's the break.
It's either, like,
was there a seal with
Latin words or a commercial?
-No, it was the one with the guy
standing in front of
the blue Subaru.
He was like, "Life was bad,
but now I got a Subaru."
And I was like,
"I need a Subaru."
[ Laughter ]
-Another thing we have in
common, I'm married to a lawyer,
so in arguments, I tend to lose.
I would imagine, based on what
you're saying here,
you don't do particularly well
when you argue.
-No. Yeah.
She just goes, "You went to
a college with a commercial."
[ Laughter ]
-You have very good producers
on this special -- Judd Apatow
and your friend Pete Davidson.
-People like those guys.
-Yeah, they like those guys.
Good guys.
You met --
I guess you guys were kids
when you met doing stand-up,
you and Pete?
-Yeah, me and Pete --
I was 21, he was 16.
He was like,
"Will you get me a beer?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Alright, kid."
And, yeah, we became friends,
and we just kicked it.
And it was fun.
We lived together.
-What was it like when Ricky
and Pete were living together?
-Our parents did not like it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We only made it eight months.
-What happened?
-Just everything turned into
an ashtray.
[ Laughter ]
I woke up once.
He was using my belly button.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Come on, man,
use your own."
[ Laughter ]
-Does he have an outie? I feel
bad for people with outie.
-That's what the problem is.
-You got an outie,
all of a sudden the ashes
are all over your whole belly,
yeah.
I want to talk about,
while we're talking about
belly buttons,
I have a photographic --
So, you made a choice.
This was not something
you were forced to do.
-I made a choice on this one.
-I want to make it clear
this wasn't HBO.
-No, Judd did not make me
do this.
-Okay. So, this is -- Do you
want to talk real quick about
what you decided to do for
the poster of your special?
-So, Mark Seliger,
amazing photographer.
The guy's a legend.
He shot Obama. He's incredible.
And Judd called me
and he's like,
"He's going to shoot you
for the special."
And I started going
through his book,
and I saw that he shot
Kim Kardashian nude.
So I was like, "He's going to
shoot Ricky Velez nude."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And he did.
-He shot me nude, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to do this
in front of HBO execs.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Do you think at any point
the photographer was like,
"Aw, man, I shot Obama"?
[ Laughter ]
-At one point he turned to me,
he goes, "I'm nervous."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Shut up."
-Did you find --
First of all, did you work out
before you took the shot?
-I was on one. Yeah, no, yeah.
-Alright. That's good.
-All of that.
-And then did you become
comfortable the longer you were
fully naked in front of
a room full of people?
-Well, it was weird because,
like, I had to keep myself
covered for it, and then,
like, we had stuff pop out.
And Mark was such a gentleman.
He'd just be like,
"Ricky, move your hand
a little bit more to the right."
[ Laughter ]
"You're ruining a great day."
He's like, "You sure
you don't want to take
any options with clothes on?"
I was like, "Nope!"
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"You definitely didn't say that
to Kim Kardashian."
[ Laughter ]
-"Let's get a coat on Kim."
Your son was born --
I mean, you know, I, obviously,
have talked about the way my
kids were born over the years.
How was yours?
-Not in a lobby.
-No, yeah. Well-planned.
-Yeah.
No, but he was born on 9/11.
-Okay.
-Yeah, he was born on 9/11.
He's Irish, Puerto Rican,
and Jewish.
So he's the most New York thing
you can get.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Kid loves a bagel.
-He loves a bagel.
[ Laughter ]
Did you participate
in the birth?
No? Okay. You were there?
-I was behind the sheet.
-Yeah, okay.
-I didn't want to see it.
I'm not good with blood.
I didn't want to go down.
And my wife turned to me
right before
she was going to have the kid,
she goes,
"If you're going to make this
about you, you need to leave."
[ Laughter ]
That's true.
And then through the curtain,
the doctor's like, "You want to
cut the umbilical cord?"
And I didn't know that word,
like --
[ Laughter ]
I went to a college with
a commercial, right?
So I was like, "No, I don't want
to cut the ability cord."
And the doctor --
[ Laughter ]
The doctor was like,
"Umbilical cord."
And I was like, "Ability cord."
He's like, "Sir, I'm pretty sure
you're saying ability cord."
I was like,
"I'm 100% saying ability cord."
[ Laughter ]
And he goes, "Why would you ever
call it that?"
And I was like, "Well, it gives
the baby abilities, correct?"
[ Laughter ]
And he said,
"That's not as dumb as I thought
it was going to be."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Good luck."
-They're going to put you
in front of the Subaru
on the new commercial.
Hey, man, congrats
on the special.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-Really appreciate
having you out here tonight.
Such a delight.
-Thank you so much.
-"Ricky Velez: Here's
Everything" premieres on HBO
and is streaming on HBO Max
on October 23rd.